Since the dawn of time, we have
raised our eyes to the sky,
observing and dreaming of the unknown
worlds that the universe might shelter.
Imagine that we could leave Earth,
and travel through space and time,
in order to explore these inaccessible
places, discovering the Cosmos.
We are one and a half billion
kilometers away from the Sun.
Seen from here, our star is no more
than a dot, lost in an immensity.
In front of us stands Saturn.
It is the sixth planet of the solar system.
Saturn is a huge ball of gas. Ten times
larger than Earth, the gas giant’s diameter
measures nearly 120,000 km, for a mass
of 500 000 billion billion tonnes.
Being so far from the Sun, it takes
almost 30 years to orbit around it.
Here, one year amounts to 11,000 days on Earth.
The very thick atmosphere of Saturn
is composed mainly of hydrogen, to which is added
some helium, and traces of other rare gases.
These gases, which are very light, provide
Saturn with a remarkably low average density.
If it could be submerged in a large enough ocean,
it would float on the surface of the water.
Covered in yellow and orange colors,
Saturn's atmosphere is far from uniform.
Its color is due to the chemical
elements that compose it.
It sometimes presents blue shades resulting from
complex phenomena related to how light scatters.
These are the same phenomena that give
our sky its blue colour, on Earth.
On Saturn’s surface, a freezing
temperature of negative 180°C prevails.
Gas clouds circulate around the planet,
and form a stack of horizontal stripes.
In this incessant flow, it sometimes
happens that huge thunderstorms form.
These extremely powerful electric storms
can last for several months and extend
over thousands of kilometers, giving rise to
raging winds that can reach incredible speeds.
At the North Pole the course of the
winds draws a very strange cloud pattern.
Its mysterious, hexagonal-shape has
yet to find a definite explanation.
In ultraviolet light, we can also
distinguish magnificent auroras.
These intriguing polar lights,
similar to those found on Earth,
arise from the interaction of solar
winds with the planet's magnetic field.
Saturn is surrounded by an impressive
system of concentric rings.
These rings are made up of fine particles of
ice and dust, which revolve around the planet.
Extremely thin, they are only
a few dozens of meters thick,
while spanning hundreds of
thousands of kilometers in radius.
The origin of these rings is still a mystery.
They are perhaps the remnants of a moon,
which would have ventured too close to the planet.
Torn and distorted by the attraction of Saturn,
it would have eventually exploded,
pulverized by the planet’s tidal forces.
Saturn is outrageously massive.
Its very strong gravitational influence
allows it to keep in orbit over sixty moons.
Some of these moons orbit inside the rings.
Among them, for instance, is Pan. Orbiting within
the Encke Gap, its gravitational pull deflects
the trajectories of surrounding particles. The
periodic passage of the satellite forces this
division to stay open, and separates the
rings which are situated on either side.
This is Prometheus, and Pandora.
Prometheus and Pandora are two shepherd
moons, which work together. Orbiting very
close to each other, the two moons deflect
the trajectories of particles around them,
and force them to be confined inside a very
narrow ring, barely a hundred kilometers wide.
As we move away from Saturn and its rings,
we encounter a wide variety of moons,
each of them with unique characteristics.
240,000 km from Saturn lies Enceladus.
Smaller than our Moon, Enceladus is however one
of Saturn's largest satellites. This moon exhibits
strange "plumes", geyser-like formations which
rise several hundred kilometers above its surface.
Composed of particles of ice, gas, and dust,
these jets of matter emerge from cryovolcanoes
scattered across the surface of the satellite.
They bear witness to an intense internal activity.
On its surface, Enceladus is covered with ice,
riddled with impact craters, and
notched with cracks and volcanic faults.
This moon remains constantly in a frozen state,
at an average temperature of negative 200°C.
Despite this very low surface temperature, the
geological activity of Enceladus betrays the
existence of an ocean of liquid water under the
ice, as well as the presence of organic compounds.
Two ingredients essential for
the development of life...
We are now more than a million
kilometers away from Saturn.
It is at this distance that its
largest satellite orbits. Titan.
Titan is home to a completely
different world from Enceladus.
Surrounded by a very dense atmosphere,
consisting mainly of nitrogen, we find
here a very rich climate, with clouds, rains…
of methane, and even seasons, like on Earth.
This thick cloud layer hides a
surface with impressive variety,
not entirely unlike some of
the landscapes found on Earth.
Crossed by rivers and lakes of methane, Titan
is also speckled with volcanoes, mountains,
and sand dunes.
Although frozen, given its distance from the
Sun, Titan surprisingly recalls the first moments
of our planet. The chemical composition of its
atmosphere contains complex organic molecules,
which might remind us of the prebiotic
conditions... at the origin of life on Earth.
Visible from the Earth, it has been
observed since prehistoric times.
Saturn has always fascinated astronomers.
Its gigantic size and majestic rings make it a
marvel of the solar system. Better known today
than ever before, it still holds many
mysteries, which have yet to be discovered.